vous avez les mains sourde vous aimé mes
mains elles sont chaudes
c'est important les mains la pauvre
c'est trois ans
vous aviez disparu se soigner mon mari
vous l'avez bien soigné éléments
j'aimerais vous aider vous avez une
jolie bouche vous aimez ma bouche à les
jolies aller j'avais parce que les crocs
voilà mes grosses mouches mon arrivée je
te courageuse
c'est votre première sortie on va dire
d'habitude
enfin depuis l'événement que vous savez
j'avais plutôt à vagues atteint dans les
squares
sur les bords de l'oise avec mon enfant
vous n'avez qu'un enfant ouais
mais je souhaite en avoir d'autres j'ai
lu beh oui je joue
j'aime mon chien cyrillus comme cha
je me dispute est souvent avec mon mari
à ce sujet il avait la malle et d'ouvrir
toutes les finales vous aviez un grand
appartement immense
tout s'est fait d'être ouverte il
prétendait que c'était plus sain il
était obsédé par la maladie de quoi
est-il mort cogestion j'adore à danser
avec j'adore danser mais c'est agréable
ce rythme là surtout parce qu'on peut
lancer tranquillement oui mon mari
déteste et la danse il détestait ça j'ai
pardonné quelquefois à l'entraîner dans
des endroits comme celui ci le seul
membre au bois du whisky tu étais vivre
je connais commencé à danser
vous êtes né de galles signe
scorpion et vous gémeaux s'adresse
winstone intéressant pourquoi y est à
l'astrologie juge un passionné de ça je
trouve que c'est une science divine
oui ces dix mois les gémeaux et les
scorpions se tient terriblement mais ça
se termine souvent très mal en crawl
jeudi j'ai eu une aventure avec un
scorpion un désastre nous allons
détruire
c'est probable c'est ça vous allez très
grosse année je vous le promets je sais
je voudrais vous échapper j'essayais
nous allons nous amuser tous les deux
nous n'allons pas nous ennuyer
je suis tellement ennuyé avec ce mot qui
me plaire
c'est que vous êtes vivant
martin veilleux sont évidents